in this segment we consider the sum of
independent Poisson random variables and
we establish a remarkable fact namely
that the sum is also Poisson this is a
fact that we can establish by using the
convolution formula the PMF of the sum
of independent random variables is the
convolution of their pmfs so we can take
two Poisson PMF convolve them carry out
the algebra and find out that in the end
you obtain again a Poisson PMF however
such a derivation is completely
unintuitive and does not give you any
insight instead we will derive this fact
by using already intuition about what
poisson random variables really
represent we will work with a Poisson
process of rate lambda equal to 1 but
let us remind ourselves of the general
Poisson PMF if we have a more general
rate lambda this is the PMF of the
number of arrivals in a Poisson process
with rate lambda during a time interval
of length tau and this Poisson PMF has a
mean equal to lambda tau and you can
think of lambda tau as being the
parameter of this Poisson PMF so we say
that this is a Poisson PMF with
parameter equal to lambda times tau now
let us consider two consecutive time
intervals in this process that have
length mu and mu and let us consider the
numbers of arrivals during each one of
these intervals so we have m arrivals
here and n arrivals there of course M
and n are random variables what kind of
random variables are they well the
number of arrivals in a Poisson process
of rate 1 over a period of duration mu
is going to have a Poisson PMF in which
lambda is 1
taou the time interval is equal to mu so
it's going to be a Poisson random
variable with parameter or mean equal to
MU similarly for n is going to be a
Poisson random variable with parameter
equal to MU are these two random
variables independent of course they are
in a Poisson process the numbers of
arrivals in disjoint time intervals are
independent random variables
what kind of random variable is there
some their sum is the total number of
arrivals during an interval of length mu
plus nu and therefore this is a Poisson
random variable with mean equal to MU
plus mu so what do we have here we have
the sum of two independent Poisson
random variables and that sum turns out
also to be a Poisson random variable
more generally if somebody gives you two
independent Poisson random variables you
can always think of them as representing
numbers of arrivals in this joint time
intervals and therefore by following
this argument their sum is going to be a
Poisson random variable and this is the
conclusion that we wanted to establish
it's a remarkable fact it's similar to
the fact that we had established four
normal random variables the sum of
independent normal random variables is
also normal
so Poisson and normal distributions are
special in this respect this is a
property that most other distributions
do not have with very few exceptions